so i am here again
with a chest up board
and you may have seen in previous videos
i used
uh some other features using assistance
and playing levon aronian but in this
video i am going to play
an otb game against an online opponent
and the way this will work is i
search for a game on me chess
i'm gonna do a five plus five
casual game
and i have the app open here uh as you
can see
and just got a game
against swans blah
play e4
and
turn the volume down so
the app is connected to the board via
bluetooth
and whenever i touch a piece it'll show
legal moves
i'm not getting any extra assistance
beyond that
and when my opponent makes a move as we
see it will light up
and i'll make the move for my opponent
so this is a very different feel
compared to
using a mouse and
uh
i'm looking at a 2d screen
um it feels like i'm more have invested
in the game
uh so here we have a grand prix attack
still following some kind of opening
theory
um
now i do have the game on my laptop i am
watching the game
to capture it uh for this overlay
my opponent is rated
2068.
opponent's actually playing what uh
very similar to what daring wrench
played against me and this speedchest
championship match
uh in our first game
and the ideas for white are pretty
simple here like go for the kingside
attack
queen h4 f5
bishop h6 knight g5
now there's no drawing arrows otb so i
do have to visualize
uh d5
is a move
i'll start with king h1
try and
remain flexible
bishop a6
yeah bishop a6 aligns with the rook
sometimes there's ideas of c4 for black
i think now is probably a good time to
play e5
just shut down the bishop on g7
and upon c4 i can play pawn d4
we're entering a more
kind of closed position
i've given up on playing f5 uh as other
kind of
pawn advance idea for white
but things can be more positional here
the idea is to play knight a4
pawn b3 c4 and really target
the c5 pawn
yeah let's go for
yes i can see all the legal moves for my
knight let's go for knight a4
so hitting the pawn on c5 if i touch the
pawn we can see one legal move
um
there is a setting on the chats where
you can uh
can turn on like legal moves when you
touch a piece
so we do see c4 here
um
yeah if i play d4 there's a pawn c3
hitting the rook
interesting
[Music]
let's start with knight c5
counter-attacking the bishop
and the bishop b5 i have a4
rook
b6
or no queen b6 ah
i have to pay attention to what's lit up
queen b6 is a very playable move
i'll play bishop e3
essentially completing development
aligning my bishop with the queen
and now i'm threatening knight takes e6
discovered attack against the queen
the queen's also tied down to the bishop
on a6
so this is looking
[Music]
very
appetizing for whites
it seems like i'll be winning some
material pretty soon
like what does black even do here
queen b5 a4
should check the time up on time up
about 20 seconds
and this is actually pretty good
training for otb
for those that
play online exclusively
if you're looking to get into tournament
chess you should really be training
using a physical board
because it's just a different feel
looking at
three-dimensional pieces
and just getting comfortable with uh
seeing the whole board
practicing your board vision
you see bishop f8
maybe setting up for the next game
so i could still play knight takes e6
hitting the queen
but knight e4 also looks like really
attractive here
i'm gonna play 94.
i'm not interested in winning a pawn
just yet
but i'm interested in
targeting the dark squares
e6
96 d6 and f6
i should probably turn off my
notifications
uh
that's another thing when you're playing
chess online or over the board you
should minimize
distractions
put your phone in do not disturb mode
oh no my pawn
i forgot that was hanging
queen digs b2
what is this
i mean
i have so many juicy looking moves
there's knight f6
knight d6
this is where you should not get too
excited you should just stay calm and
try and calculate the best option
knight f6 forces king d8
and then probably queen a5 winning the
bishop yeah let's do that
queen a5 it's a very important move to
see it's uh
usually in this line i play queen e1 to
go to h4 but uh
nice when the queen is centralized it
can access both sides of the board
and the problem for black is uh the
bishop is controlling b6 so there's no
rook b6
there is rook b6 actually but then i
take
or actually if rook b6 i play rook b1
even stronger
black is in big trouble here
opponent uh
yeah down a bit about a minute on the
clock but uh
that's probably the least of their
problems here
might as well adjust the pieces
we have king 2
c8
the obvious move of course is queen
takes a6 but
always look for stronger
queen a6 does the job
expecting rook b7 or queen b7
and now it's very important because
usually
a lot of players are told that when
you're up material you should trade but
there's another general rule in chess is
that when you're attacking your
opponent's king is less safe
you should avoid the queen trade
and
definitely want to keep queens on the
board here
keeping queens on the board should
allow things to finish quicker
now the question is what am i
threatening knight f5
a7 is
looking vulnerable but if i take on a7
again we're not playing touch move see
the legal moves
bishop takes a7 there's rook a8
considering rook b1 here b1 queen b1
trade trade
give away two rooks for the queen
how's my time falling below two minutes
what if i play something like bishop f2
bishop f2 bishop 4.84 play bishop f2
it's important i would just want to play
g4 kick away the knight
and now i'm targeting c6 with the queen
so queen on b7 is tied down to c6
and if queen b5 i'm in a7
and now i do want to play rook b1 next
and it's nice being up a piece
up on time
bishop
c3 oh there's a funny line okay i'm
going to play rook p1
allowing
queen digs b1
which looks decent at first queen b1
rogue p1 rook b1
opponent's not falling for it though
if queen b1 i would have taken on c6
made into
opponents resisting let's take the rook
and
just adjust
rook b1 king a8
rp1 king 8 bishop b6
i mean looks like there's so many good
moves here
play queen a3
essentially trapping the bishop
23.85
uh choices choices
wait
rook b1 bishop a7
oh it's a nice line okay rick b1
i feel like it's more satisfying to play
nice lines over the board
get that satisfaction of
seizing europeans pieces
and pawns
and maybe king
so the idea is of queen a7
i take on c6
and i'm threatening
just running any bishop move basically
so bishop a5
now i have bishop b6 anyway
creating the pin on the a file
forking the queen in bishop
take the bishop on a5
and
my opponent has resigned
uh yeah just to show
if king b8
i would play
checkmate
and we get the cool cool effects
so anyway uh i hope people enjoy this
let me know if you have any feedback
this is uh this is very new to play
otd against an online opponent
um i think this is a really cool product
uh very curious what people think
leave your thoughts below and if you're
interested in learning more about
chessup
uh be sure to take a look at links in
the description
i do have a special offer for my viewers
you can use coupon code rosen to save on
your chessup order
and
stay tuned for more otd content